less than 24 hours after one of the most
shocking moments in oscar history will
smith apologizes to chris rock but
here's the question is it enough welcome
to entertainment tonight nichelle turner
is off today
the aftershocks of the slap still being
felt all over hollywood but it's clear
the comedy world oh they're
overwhelmingly team rock
i was sickened i was sickened by the
standing ovation
i felt like hollywood is just spineless
on mass no one lifted a finger
spider-man was there
aquaman was there
catwoman all sitting on their hands
that is the worst thing will smith has
ever done wait i forgot about wild wild
west
even kanye was like you went on stage
and did what an award show
we don't talk about jada no no no i had
announced this morning that i was suing
will for 200 million dollars because
that video is going to be there forever
it's going to be ubiquitous
what's been happening behind closed
doors at the smith family compound a
source tells e.t will does not regret
sticking up for jada but he does have
remorse for how he went about it he
acted out of impulse jada meanwhile was
hurt by chris's remark making fun of her
appearance this morning she called for
healing on instagram and just last week
in a tick tock video captioned be proud
of your crown she said she fully
embraced her beautiful bald look i don't
give two craps what people feel about
this bald head of mine because guess
what
i love it
publicly we'll apologize to chris for
the onstage slap in a statement the
oscar winner said he was out of line
wrong and embarrassed but despite will's
maia culpa a source tells e.t that chris
and will have not patched things up also
weighing in will's mom who told the abc
affiliate in philadelphia she was
surprised that's the first time i've
ever seen him
go off
the first time
in his lifetime
this morning will's daughter willow
wrote you know who's going through a lot
right now literally everyone richard
williams the father of venus and serena
williams who will portray and king
richard said quote we don't condone
anyone hitting anyone else unless it's
in self-defense today we're also
learning more about the chaos that
unfolded behind the scenes
a source tells e.t having will removed
was definitely discussed seriously the
reason people got up and went over to
him is because i think a lot of people
thought oh my god is he having a break
he said do we need to get him out what
do we need to do we're also told people
were checking that chris rock was okay
and to see if chris even wanted to press
charges i like that they go well chris
rock didn't press any charges why does
chris rock have to press charges
so what's next for will well we could
learn that tomorrow when the academy
including whoopi goldberg who's on the
board of governors meets to discuss his
fate there are consequences there are
big consequences there has to be
e.t has spoken with three academy
members they told us they would not vote
to take will's oscar away experts point
out the academy has not revoked oscar
wins for even the most disgraced winners
like harvey weinstein and roman polanski
down to the timeline leading up to the
oscar slap will and chris go way back
and first worked together nearly 30
years ago now which one of you handsome
men's is big willy
[Applause]
in 1995 chris was a guest star on the
fresh prince playing will's blind date
jasmine i hear they have nude beaches
in 1999 chris and will reunited the
premiere of the matrix a lot of action
can you fight
uh i could fight in the movies very well
out here in the street no who could kick
who's back everybody says he's apple pie
do not get it twisted all right
no no no no no i just just try to make
sure my honey's taken care of
six years later in 2005 jada and chris
were the ones cast together in
madagascar let's not talk about that
chris all right now
the two appeared to be on good terms
while doing press and even presented
will with a kid's choice award nothing
but love y'all
then came 2016 when then host chris
secured jada for boycotting the oscars
jaina says she's not coming
protesting i'm like is she on a tv show
it's also not fair that will was paid 20
million for wild wild west okay
any
i'm
daughter
rock hey look that comes with the
territory but we got to keep it moving
and throughout it all will and jada
always had each other's backs jada and i
have you know we weathered some storms
we have
found so much happiness in our union
yeah in a way that's very different than
most no doubt their 24-year marriage is
unconventional jada calls will her life
partner not husband they have also faced
rumors of having an open marriage you're
getting divorced again am i and i don't
have a ring on oh it must be true
basically like oh he has an open
relationship that's that's not exactly
it the pack that we have made to one
another is that i will deliver myself to
her happy and she will deliver herself
to me happy in 2020 jada did admit to a
years-long extramarital relationship
with r b singer august alcina as time
went on i got into a different kind of
entanglement
with august an entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely
while it remains to be seen how the
oscar assault will affect will's career
prices for chris's ego death world tour
have surged from around forty six
dollars to more than four hundred
dollars per ticket the comedy tour kicks
off tomorrow in boston
you